ثوره حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث نفت هيئه
الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه السيطره
الروسيه على مدينه باخموت وقالت انها
تتصدى لكثير من هجمات العدو الاركان
الاوكرانيه ايضا في موقعها على فيسبوك
قالت ان العدو لم يوقف هجومه على باخموت
مضيفه من المدافعين الاوكرانيين يسيطرون
بشجاعه على المدينه وصدوا كثيرا من هجمات
العدو واشارت الاركان الاوكرانيه الى ان
روسيا تواصل تركيز الجزء الاكبر من جهودها
على تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه في قطاعات ليبان
ومارينكا مؤكده صد كثير من الهجمات
المعاديه على
وبدورها اكلت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
باخموت لا تزال تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه وصفه اخبار سيطره القوات
الروسيه عليها بالمزيفه وغير الحقيقيه
ياتي ذلك ردا على مؤسس شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه التي اعلن فيها
دخول قوته الى وسط المدينه وكان رئيس شركه
قال في وقت سابق ليله امس ان مقاتليه
رفعوا العلم الروسيه ورايه قواته على
المبنى الاداري في مركز باخمت لكنه اقر
لان القوات الاوكرانيه لا تزال موجوده في
الاجزاء الغربيه من المدينه
الثاني من ابريل الساعه الحاديه عشره ليلا
تماما وخلفي مبنى اداره المدينه هذا علم
روسيا مكتوب عليه
من الناحيه القانونيه استولينا على سيرفع
قاده الوحدات التي سيطرت على المبنى
الاداري والحي المركزي هذا العلم
سيطرنا على المدينه ولكن العدو لا يزال
متواجدا في الاحياء الغربيه
امل كيف مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود ومن
دونتسك مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي طبعا
محل انظار الجميع وابدا بكرانيا وما يقوله
وما خرج من رئيس مجموعه فاجنر ان هنالك
انهم رفعوا العلم الروسي وعلم المجموعه
على المبنى الاداري بواسطه المدينه لكن هو
يعترف بان غرب المدينه ما زال بحوزه
الاوكرانيين
نعم زين بالفعل مالك شركه فار اكد انه تمت
السيطره على المبنى الاداري في في قلب
مدينه باقمه وتم رفع العلم الروسي ورايت
قواته على هذا المبنى فضلا عن ذلك تم
التاكيد ايضا على السيطره على الاحياء
المركزيه في مدينه باخمت وبذلك حسب تعبيره
يمكن القول ان القوات الروسيه سيطرت من
الناحيه القانونيه على مدينه باخوهن
بالاشاره الا انه على ما يبدو زين بانه
بمجرد السيطره على مركز المدينه يمكن
القول انه تمت السيطره على قلب هذه
المدينه نعم بالفعل هناك تاكيد من قبله ان
قوات الاوكرانيه باتت تنسحب في نحو
المناطق الغربيه حيث لا تزال لها توجد
تعزيزات فضلا عن ذلك يعني بالفعل لا يمكن
القول حتى هذه اللحظه انه من الناحيه
العمليه تمت السيطره على كل ارجاء واخذ
المعارك لا تزال تجري نحن
عن حرب شوارع لا تزال تجري في مختلف ارجاء
مدينه ليس فقط في الغرب بل في بعض الاحياء
الشماليه الجنوبيه ولكن لو تحدثنا عن
التعزيزات والتواجد العسكريه الاوكراني
على الاقل بحسب تصريحات فريجوجل لا يزال
متواجدا في الغرب وهناك ايضا معطيات
عسكريه تتحدث عن ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه بالطبع الحديث يدور عن قوات يعني
تتقدم شيئا فشيئا في مختلف هذه المناطق
وايضا تقوم بقصف مواقع القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه التي لا تزال متواجده في داخل
مدينه باخم فضلا عن ذلك المعارك مستمره
ايضا في محور هذه المدينه الحديث يدور
بحسب المصادر العسكريه هنا في دانيس عن
قصف
القوات الروسيه خلال اليوم الماضي لمواقع
تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه ليس في داخل
المدينه وحسب بل وفي الاجنحه المحيطه بها
الحديث يدور هنا عن
في مدينه كنستانتين التي تقع غربي مدينه
بوخمط وايضا عن منطقه كراسنا التي تقع
جنوب غرب مدينه وهنا اود الاشاره لان يعني
تم الاعلان امس عن ان الطريق الذي يربط
بمدينه
بالمنطقه يعني سيطره القوات الروسيه بشكل
عام هنا لابد من الاشاره سريع ازدهار الى
ان كان قد اعلن في وقت سابق انه بمجرد
السيطره على مدينه
سيفتح الطريق للقوات الروسيه للتقدم نحو
العمق الاوكراني وكان قد اكد ان ان قواته
فعليا قد قضت على الجيش الاوكراني في داخل
المدينه اما فيما يتعلق بحرب الشوارع فهنا
ود الاشاره الى تصريحات روسيه صدرت سابقا
ان مساله السيطره بشكل كامل على مدينه هي
مساله ايام او اسابيع على الاكثر بذلك الى
حسان مسعود هل من روايه اوكرانيا تفند
الروايه الروسيه المتعلقه بباخمت
نعم ازدهار قبل دقائق فقط اعلن الرئيس
المكتب الرئاسي في اوكرانيا اندريه في
تغريده على تويتر نفيه بشكل واضح
لسيطره قوات فاجنر على بخمه وقال ان
اوكران ان باخموت اوكرانيه
وطالب الاوكرانيين بعدم الالتفات الى هذا
النصر المزعوم الذي ليس حتى قريب من
الواقع وفق تعبيره ووفق كلماته كان هذا هو
النفي الاوضح الصادر عن الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه حتى هذه اللحظه
وهذا التصريح ياتي في سياق عددا من
التصريحات التي تزامنت مع اعلان مالك شركه
فاجنر عن رفع العلم على المبنى الاداري في
مدينه باخمت كان يشير الى ان الوضع في
باخمه صعب للغايه كان متوترا جدا خلال
اليوم الماضي وهذا جاء على لسان حتى
الرئيس الاوكراني
الذي كان قد اكد ان الوضع في بخموت خلال
اليوم الماضي كان بشكل خاص صعبا للغايه
وقام بتوجيه التحيه للذين ما زالوا
يشاركون في الدفاع عن هذه المدينه كما عن
عدد من المدن الاوكرانيه وهذا يشير الى ان
القتال في باخمت ما زال مستمرا وان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت مصره على الاستمرار في
القتال هناك هذا ايضا جاء على لسان هيئه
الاركان العليا الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت
اليوم عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تتصدى لهجمات في منطقه باخموت وانها قامت
بعشرين اشتباكا في احياء ومناطق باخمه
والمناطق المحيطه بالمدينه
ان القوات الروسيه لا تتوقف عن محاوله
اقتحام باخمت والسيطره عليها بشكل كامل
وهذا ايضا يعتبر تصريحا جديدا يفيد بان
الوضع هناك صعب للغايه وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول صد محاوله السيطره
الكامله على مدينه
كل ذلك ايضا ياتي في اطار مواصله القتال
في منطقه بخموت هذا ايضا جاء على لسان
نائبه وزير الدفاع ايضا التي قالت ان
وحدات من المظاليين الروس ايضا يشاركون
قوات في القتال هناك شكرا لك
شكرا ايضا
لمراسله الجزيره من دونيتسك رانيا